je vais dire un truc moi y'a plein de
gens aussi sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
plein de journalistes qui ont dit oui il
va être obligé d'aller xian n'a pas ce
que c'est adna qui ne veux pas que tu
reviennes sur ces mots oui quand je vais
tous les pressions aussi avec une
organisation auprès de thierry ardisson
que vous restez pas ici mon moi je vais
te dire moi jerem moi je ne me réjouis
jamais du malheur des autres
donc je vais te dire moi franchement que
tu reviennes à l'antenne mois sur ces
vite ça ne me dérange pas du tout je
vais te dire 6-1 ni son essai 8 pas le
travail avec toi motion il nie le
producteur de l'émission ni le patron de
la chaîne
moi je me réjouis jamais donc de je te
dis du malheur des autres donc j'espère
que tu vas revenir antennes si tu es
heureux
je serais heureux pour toi je te le dis
moi j'ai été vexé juste que tu ailles
voilà à la norme à la concurrence qui
est maintenant je pense voilà ça c'est
assez logique
maintenant je vais te dire moi tu me
connais je m'énerve très vite après j'ai
quand même un bon coeur et si je peux
t'aider
et si je peux te défendre auprès de ses
8 si bien sûr je te dis on apprend que
dans ton histoire vraiment eu hélas
aujourd'hui de l'année où ted avait tout
soupçon voilà de 2,2 ce qui s'est passé
voilà bon baron rentrée n'a pas
d'histoire et puis je n'arrive même pas
à comprendre d'ailleurs pourquoi je suis
sur la sellette alors présents mais sans
fin voilà donc toi tu aimerais revenir à
l'antenne
bah oui je veux aussi vous voulez enfin
moi mais moi c'est pas moi qui décide si
vous voulez ça je me suis rendu compte
pendant cette période que voilà vraiment
ce que je faisais ce que je faisais chez
thierry ardisson voilà c'était quelque
chose d' extrêmement valorisant et
enrichissant
thierry ardisson m'a ouvert on va dire
les portes d'un monde un peu plus
réelles parce que j'avais un petit peu
fini ces derniers temps par mme noyés
dans ma baignoire
j'avais complètement occulté ce qui
m'entoure les problématiques
ma foi politique sociétale géré
évidemment que oui j'ai envie de
réintégrer l'équipe et mes camarades
tiré à quelques hommes tout ce que
j'aime j'ai thierry qui m'envoient merci
cyril de rétablir la vérité
hindi 6 et 8 accepte je le reprends tout
de suite voilà donc tu vois thierry
voilà donc va voir la chaîne demain oui
dans les jours prochains mois je vais te
dire je te le dis moi je suis vraiment
je vous dis je le redis moi je ne mets
jamais de bâtons dans les roues jantes
en plein de choses des conneries qui
sont dites sur twitter holder les
journalistes j'irai mais ce que je t'ai
déjà mis des bâtons dans les roues dit
la vérité que nos attentes a été très
sympathique mais tu m'as d'ailleurs
jamais fait de chantage voir se laisse
assez bon enfin c'est toujours là
mais n'importe quoi voilà je voulais te
dire moi j'espère que tu vas faire ton
chemin j'espère que si tout va bien pour
toi et si des affaires car on est très
vite et l'après a priori tu me dis que
c'est arrangé
j'espère que tu vas revenir sur ces vite
et thierry est prêtre reprend je sais
qu'il y en a qui vont m'en vouloir
autour de la table c'est bien parce que
vous lui tirez mis sur la chaîne à cause
de ce qu'il a fait mais il a fait quoi
non pas parce qu'il est allé sur tmc
m'expliquer que l'a expliqué que c'était
pas que sa faute pas sa voix là après
moi je subis des pressions de la chaîne
de son producteur mais de la concurrence
forcément c'est compliqué et moi je lui
dis je pour le pardon
voilà il y a été il est à lille est allé
très vite moi je trouve que tu iras
indices ou jeu quand même un jeu bizarre
ms pour expliquer ce qui se passe
attendez damas fille appât fille qui dit
non pardon mais moi je suis content
voilà allez merci on en reparlera demain
tout ça en bas revenir là dessus et on
va parler de valeurs dollar action qui
rit et des réactions là dessus en début
d'émission jir m
en tout cas ce que tu un dernier moyen
non si ce n'est que voilà j'espère
retrouver cette équipe que j'aime tant
qui m'a beaucoup manqué qui m'a quand
même beaucoup soutenu thierry stéphane
simon et ayem garrido gilles william
goldnadel tous ces gens qui concerne
actionne tu étais content d'aller sur
tmc quand même